qui de mieux qu'un acteur du casting
d'un film pour le présenter c'était le
rôle de jacques narcy dire fussent lors
du ciné débat autour du film au nom de
la terre à vivre samedi 19 juin dernier
sa part sur un constat bizarre c'est que
deux agriculteurs presque par jour se
suicide en france donc c'est l'histoire
d'un petit gars qui regarde son père et
son grand-père évoluer dans les soucis
l'agriculture et qui essaie de se faire
une opinion pour savoir si lui il va
devenir agriculteur ou pas ce qui est
dit la grande question qu'est ce qui
ferait de nous l'un agriculteurs
aujourd'hui en france ou bien est-ce que
c'est un métier trop dangereux après la
diffusion du film en début de soirée un
débat a eu lieu autour des
problématiques de l'agriculture
c'est un film pour moi qui ai juste
intéressant dans le sens où rim entre
une réalité de l'agriculture qu'on voit
pas souvent qui souvent tabou parce que
ces deux sont des métiers où il ya
beaucoup de fierté de pudeur et il a au
moins 7
vraiment ce mérite d'oser mettre des
mots ou des fois des non-dits mais qui
en disent beaucoup sur certaines
particularités de l'agriculture et pas
forcément qu'on aime voir où le meilleur
aspect mais qui est une réalité
quotidienne pour certains ce moment des
changes a été organisé par la première
adjointe de la ville
avec aussi un objectif d'ouvrir le débat
sur les enjeux de l'agriculture de
demain se fournir à proximité chez des
producteurs de la région
manger des produits de saison évitez
aussi les intermédiaires les
intermédiaires qui prennent à chaque
fois des marges
du coup c'est un moyen de permettre aux
agriculteurs de produire bien d'être
fiers de leur production et c'est aussi
une solution gagnant gagnant puisque les
consommateurs eux parviennent à donner
du sens à leur consommation peut être
une partie de la solution pour que les
agriculteurs ne soit pas demain comme
dans le film au nom de la terre au pied
du mur